[موسيقى]
على مرتفعات تيغري الاثيوبيه يتم انتاج
اشهر منتج في
المنطقه العسل
الابيض لكن صنع منتج بهذه الحلاوه عمليه
مريره جدا سيكو والبقيه من مربي العسل
يتسلقون التلال الحاده هذا الى حيث توجد
حظيره خلايا النحل انهم يستخدمون صناديق
حديثه لخليه النحل وهي التي تنتج عسلا
اكثر من الصناديق
التقليديه فالخلايا الحديثه تضمن الحفاظ
على ورق شمع العسل وهذا يدفع النحل الى
التركيز على صنع العسل بدلا من
الشمع ولكن لا يمكن لجمع العسل ان يبدا
بدون عنصر اساسي ومهم
للغايه انه الدخان وهو ضروري لتهدئه النحل
فهذا النحل الافريقي خطير جدا بل
قاتل ورغم تعود المزارعين عليه في هذه
المرحله الا ان النحل قد يكون مزعجا اثناء
عمليه استخراج العسل فبعد استخراج القليل
منه يفر المربون الى اعلى هرب من
النحل ولكن تحديدا من النحل الذي لا
يستسلم ويلحق بهم فيضطر المربون الى اشعال
المزيد من
الدخان ثم يتم وضع الاطارات في مستخرج
العسل والذي يقوم بالدوران للقيام
بالعمليه
المطلوبه لكن النحل لن يتخلى عن عسله بهذه
السهوله مما يدفع المربين الى الذهاب الى
مناطق اكثر
ارتفاعا بعد عناء طويل يشعر الم بالراحه
لاستخراج الذهب السائل
الاثيوبي لكن سرعان ما يلحق بهم النحل من
جديد ومع غروب الشمس يتسلقون اكثر المناطق
ارتفاعا للاستمتاع بما حصلوا عليه
اليوم ويباع هذا العسل لقرى مجاوره وشركات
محليه ويستخدم غذاء ودواء ولكن اشهر
استخدام
تكون لنبي
[موسيقى]
العسل